[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
Now the antichrist even in their
scripture says that it will be a man. A
man man what will this man claim? He
will say I am God. Now I'm asking a very
simple question. I don't even want to
shout. Which religion?
believes that God
came to earth and is a man and claims to
be. Bro, look, there's no difference
between Allah and look at the camera.
Look at Turn the camera to these guys.
Turn the camera, bro. The Muslims are in
shock because they don't know.
Guys, do you believe Jesus is God? Of
course. Do you believe that Allah is you
know you said do you believe Allah? No.
You asked, you know, you asked me, do
you pray? Do you believe that Allah? Do
you do you remember? Do you remember you
said to me that you remember you said to
me do you pray facing the heavens? I'm
doing it now. Oh Allah help me. But will
Allah guys do you know why they're
avoiding it? Because they believe let's
not shout over each other. They believe
Okay. Sorry. They believe they believe I
don't give any excuse. They believe
Jesus was a man. Is he a man? He's both
fully man. Fully God. Okay. He was a
man. I believe Allah is a man. And he is
God. there. Now I'm asking a simple
question. The antichrist when he comes
back and he's got powers because the
Bible say he's got powers. He's going to
do something you know that no more
people can do and he comes and says I am
God. Would the Christians or the Muslims
fall for his trap? The Muslims. The
Muslims Muhammad says the Muslims will
fall for. What are you talking about? I
know that I'm talking about generally
I'm talking about that if who believes
God is a man in the flesh. The
Christians are the Muslims. Okay, hold
on. Look, I'm going with you. You're a
Christian. We Christians believe. Do you
not believe Jesus is a Christian? Don't
buy into it. Don't buy into it. Don't
buy
into you as a distraction. Listen, I
know she has to be not the church. It's
not the church. Don't do it. Don't do
that. Is
Jesus do that right now? There is three
parts to God. Don't do that. Not the
father. Listen, she's not in the church.
Be quiet. in the church, the Lord the
Father, God the Father, God the Son, and
God the Holy Spirit. Now listen to us
that we're made of three parts, body,
soul, and spirit. And when God came, God
sat on the throne and allowed his son to
come to earth.
Yeah. To redeem man. To redeem man. To
redeem man. There was and to redeem man
and he became flesh. Okay. But God,
yeah, a sincere Christian who just
preached the gospel. She said clearly a
a a a a in flesh. He came in flesh. He
became healed.
He became so divinely because there was
no other seed that could be pure enough
to represent him. No. No. Just my
question please. Therefore, the
antichrist ask question. The antichrist
is a man that claims to be divine and
the only religion that believes God is a
man and that is divine is Christianity.
So then answer this question. It's
Christianity. So why does Muhammad So
why does Muhammad say that the Muslims
will get confused with him? Hold on. Why
do why do the Muslims say guys y'all
helping him distract? Y'all helping him
get away. Stop letting them get away.
Y'all be quiet. All right. I'm doing
American now. Y'all y'all What's the
donation y'all? So the question is the
question is if the if if Muslims are not
the ones who believe that God took on
flesh and became man it's only the
Christians why is it then that the
Muslims according to Muhammad will get
deceived by the dal exactly because not
only that the hadith says that he will
have kufur written in his head so so not
let me finish not only that there will
be a boy that will come to him and he
will get the boy and slice him in half
and put him back together cuz he has
those powers we believe the antichrist
will have those powers and let me you
guys don't believe I'm finished. He will
say, "Do you now believe I am your
Lord?" And he will say, "Rather now I
believe further you're not my Lord."
Why? Because there are Muslims who look,
we have Muslims today who fall into.
There are Muslims who go to the grave.
They go to the grave of the Prophet
Muhammad and think the Prophet Muhammad
can help him. What's your point? Now,
the point is is here though. The
Antichrist religion is what?
Christianity. Because they're the ones
that believe God is a man. Okay. So, now
let me respond to you on this. With no
disrespect, sister. I'll just No
disrespect. Yeah. Yeah. Just dispect.
Let me respond now. Let me let me
respond. What is it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Now, now this is now now this is the
confusion here. And he let me Thank you.
I just let you. Now, notice the
confusion here. According according to
Muhammad, according to Muhammad, it's
the Muslims that will be confused about
the dal, not
the Okay, but that's what Muhammad says.
But listen, let me tell you what
Muhammad doesn't say that you'll be
deceived by his m by his powers and the
miracles that he does. He says so that
you don't get him confused with your
Lord. So that you don't get the man the
dal the antichrist who's a man confused
with Allah which I don't know how you'll
do it because Allah is not a man right
you get confused let me land it let me
land it okay if you if if just so that
you don't get confused the antichrist
with the djal he's hento he's
curlyhaired he's short but just know
that your lord is not oneeyed he is
oneeyed but Allah he's not one eyed
that's how you can tell the difference
okay No, they're virtually identical.
Mhm. They're identical. You see where
this is coming from? Because they
believe God, do you not? No. Because you
believe God is a man. You This is why I
don't blame you. Because Because you
believe God is a man, you have to apply
that to everything you see. All you see
is the Trinity. All you see is fully
man, fully God. Let me tell you, let me
tell you what. Because you've looked at
the narration that says hair and this
that. You're thinking, "Hey, we believe
God is a man. Hair, eyes. Oh my gosh,
that sounds like Jesus. Oh no, Muslims
believe in that as well." Nice try. Why
we're doing this? You don't believe he
has curly hair? Why do this though? Can
you imagine? Muslim, do you believe
Allah has curly hair? No. I don't care
about what they believe. I care about
what the hadith. Guys, guys, guys,
please. Well, this is this is your best
argument. No, but I'm I'm talking to
you. You're not what I'm saying. Did you
come all the way from
America? There's nothing but curly hair.
Okay. So, so what's the problem? What's
the problem? Let me tell you about the
problem. By the way, hold on. You know
what I'm going to Why does he give this?
You know what I'm going to do? You know
what I'm going to do? Has curly hair on
his short. You know what I'm going to
do? Let me do this. Yeah. Let's put
Christianity and Islam to aside. Oh my
goodness. I just want you to deal with
something. Look, I'm going to deal with
one thing. And you're not going to
forget this for the rest of your life.
And we're going to we're somewhere where
it looks like Time Square, but it's not.
Picadill Circus. Remember this date.
What's the date today? The 31st of May.
It's 11:30. I'm just waiting on him to
touch on what I said. I just want to
know why is it that he and Allah are
virtually identical. Okay, let's let's
let's let's let's have a first disc.
Let's have a fair discussion. Deception
of the enemy is deception. It's
deception. That's how the enemy
deceives. And and you know the only way
you can know Jesus through him revealing
himself to you and you have to accept
him. It's so si sister, what is the wage
of sin? Yes. Why are you turning away?
And blood sacrifice. Why are you turning
away? Who does blood? No, no, no. The
blood. So, so can I say no? She asked
me. No, she asked me a question. You
switched to her. You switched to her.
Focus. Sister, I'm not going to come to
you cuz they're blaming me. Forgive me.
Yes, I'm blaming you. So, focus. It came
from them. I don't think I'm ignoring
it. Okay. So, this is what I need you to
do. Wait, wait. I'm going to give you
the mic. In Christianity, I'm going to
give it to you. They believe in the wage
of sin is death. When when she deal with
the Are you married? Can you deal with
the Are you married? When your wife
gives birth when your when your wife
gives birth is Are you Are you guys
married? Yes, we're married. Call me to
come to your wedding. I'm going to come
to your wedding now. But can you when
your wife gives birth and she's in pain,
she's she's suffering what? Can you
answer the question? What do you mean
exactly? Can you answer the question?
I'm asking you a question. You're asking
Islam. In Islam, there is no The wage of
sin is death. There is no blood
sacrifice. We don't eat flesh. You have
repented you sin. You repent. Okay. How
did Alhamdulillah? How did Allah ransom?
Alhamdulillah. How did Allah, brothers
and sisters, how did Allah I'm going to
give you. How did Allah ransom Abraham's
son? If you can prove to me Christianity
is the truth, I'm going to accept
Christianity. I'm going to accept
Christianity today. You begin. If you
can prove to me that Jesus is God, I'm
going to accept Christianity. Oh,
really? I'm going to give you I'm going
to give you an argument.
And if you can do cuz this argument is
fair. Yeah. Where's where? He said if I
can prove that Jesus is God, he going to
have you got it. Have you got camera?
Oh, the battery had in the wrong time.
Anyway, back up. Back up cameras.
Yeshua. Alhamdulillah. Now they even
have to copy us. Allah have the word.
Okay. Now brothers and sisters, I'm
going to give an argument that is going
to be fair. Totally fair. Do you mind
your camera's getting in the way of our
camera? Sorry. Sorry. Okay guys, I'm
going to give him the argument from
contingency. And if he proves through
this argument, a counterargument, this
is not about Islam. This is not about
Christianity. We're moving out. Do you
know how you left the conversation? No,
I'm still in the conversation. No, but
you left about the versus. Yes, we
already deal with that. What? We haven't
done. You said Allah has curly hair and
I said the arguments are curly. I'm
trying to show you. This is what I asked
you. Look, this is what I asked you. We
done with that. That's done. No, but you
didn't answer my question. Of course, I
answered. Okay, look. I You know what?
If you just answer it, I won't even
argue with the I answered it. I told you
that the man who came and he split him
in half. He said, "Rather, I know now
more that you know my Lord." That's not
what I'm asking. I'm asking about this
particular Okay. I'm going to Okay.
Yeah, sir. I'm asking specifically about
what Muhammad said on why he's worried
that you guys will get him
confused with Allah. He's worried about
it. Okay. And so he then begins to
describe what the djal looks like and
gives the difference with Allah. So he
says the the dal's hento curlyhaired
short. However, just know that your lord
is not one eye. So the way you tell the
difference according to Muhammad is that
Allah is not oneeyed like the dal is.
Everything else though virtually
identical. That's what you had. That's
what I understood. How do you break that
down? The only reason you understand
that from the hadith is because you're a
trinitarian that believes God is fully
man and fully God.
So when you believe God is a man, when
you believe chicken,
when you believe God is a man, you see
him everywhere. So when says he's
thinking, yo, Jesus. No, I'm explaining.
The hadith says what? The young boy came
to him and when he split him in half,
did he say, "Hold on a second. The
splitting me in half was not the issue."
Because you're not one eyed. That's not
the hadith. I'm talking about another
asking about this one. But but I'm
telling you, you don't take it in
isolation. Okay? So at least break this.
When I quote the Bible, you don't say
Ali just the top one verse. We take it
in context. This has nothing to do with
that context. Exactly. So now these are
two completely different contextes.
Listen. So, can you tell Sam? By the
way, tell him that it's closed in a half
now. When it's back on, we're still
here, but tell him to move the daw
table. Now, can we have a discussion?
These guys are talking now, brothers and
sisters, I want to go to the argument
because the cross of this matter of our
difference is Islam or Christianity.
Okay, that's that's the cross of the
matter. Okay. Now, notice how you didn't
you didn't do that. I I I I answered and
I said I answered and I said the man who
got split in half when he was brought
back, he did not say because you have
two eyes. I told you you're not my lord.
He said now I'm f to know that you're
not my understand. Can you explain?
That's another can you explain why
Muhammad describes these differences and
says your lord is not one. That shows
that number one, we know from Islam, the
Quran and the Sunnah that Allah is not a
man. So then why would they get
confused? But why does he break this?
Look, look, look, look. He didn't say
you get confused. He literally does.
He's given a description and the man who
got split in half knew by the show. I
know already. Okay, so you know what
says that they'll get confused. Look,
you're running away from the You're
running away from the argument. You're
okay. Now I'm asking a simple question.
So we're done with it. Let's let's This
already done a long time ago. Allah has
curly hair. You forfeited this. No
problem. You forfeited it. I gave up. I
quit. I know. I know. No problem. Let's
move on. Okay. Now guys, an argument for
contingency. This is an argument that
Yes. Yes. Now, Christianity, Islam, all
religions aside, logic and rational
logic. Okay. Alhamdulillah. Okay. And
this is from the Quran. This argument is
from the surah. Anyways, now why this
guy's shouting, bro? Can I can we go a
bit further there? Sam. Yeah, we can.
Sam. Sam. Sam. Sam, please, bro. Please
sit up. Okay, guys. Now, I want to know
if Jesus Hey, don't party just started,
bro. What's going on? Y'all trying to
Oh, sorry.
Y'all trying to go. Okay. Anyways,
listen y'all. Okay. Now, brothers and
sisters, this argument is going to fully
fully
establish tohed or trinity. Period. He
defines. Now, now brothers and sisters,
let's go. Now, brothers and sisters, the
first thing I'm going to say is this.
There are three types of existence.
Three types of existence. There's three
types of existence. Okay? There is
impossible existence. Impossible
existence. Yes. There is possible
existence. There's possible existence.
And there is necessary existence. All
right. What what define like I'm going
to give you the definition. Yeah. Give
me an example of an impossible
existence. Okay. So there are three
types of existence. Okay. Impossible
existence is like having a triangle
square. So does it exist? No. So it
doesn't exist. It's an impossible
existence. So it doesn't exist. No, it
won't exist. You can't have a triangle
square. So then there's only two types
of existences right now. No, we're going
to come to that. We're doing it bit by
bit. Oh yeah, we just eliminated one of
them. Yeah. Yeah. That's our whole
point. were eliminated to to come to.
Okay. Okay. The first one is an
impossible existence. Why? How many
sides does a triangle have? Three. How
many sides does a square have? Four. So
that's why it's an impossible existence
cuz you're going to have a triangle
square. So it doesn't exist. It doesn't
exist. Okay. So that's not an existence.
Yes. But bear in mind, I'm going to come
to the triangle square a bit later, but
it doesn't exist. Now we have two types
of existence left. Okay. The the the uh
possible existence is for example me you
our planet, our solar system, uh the
sun, the galaxies, etc. Why? My
definition of a contingent being a
possible existence is that something
that relies on something else for its
existence. It can be composed of pieces
and it can be any other way.
So that means I am dependent, you are
dependent, our planet is dependent, the
sun is dependent, the galaxies are
dependent. Right? Now we cannot have an
infinite regress of dependent things. Do
you agree? Yes. Okay, good. So we say
that there has to be a necessary being.
How would you define dependence? Okay.
So dependency is something that relies
on something else for it existence. It
can be composed of pieces and it can be
any other way. Good. Good. So we say
that you cannot have an infinite regress
of dependent things. Which means we need
a independent necessary being that
cannot be any other way and cannot be
composed of pieces. Got it. Perfect. Now
be composed of pieces. Yes. All right.
Good. Now,
was Jesus dependent or independent? He's
independent. He's independent. Yes.
Okay. So, my definition of dependency
was something that relies on something
else for it existence. Yeah. You you
said something that relies on another.
It can be any other way and it's and
it's not composed of pieces. So, all
right. So, is all three of those. No.
So, when you talk you said dependence,
right? Dependence is relying on
something outside of your outside of
your being, right? No. depending on it
depends on it's your dependence requires
on something else for when you say
something else when for example I need
water I need to sleep the the planet
needs the sun to be a perfect distance
so we don't freeze to death uh the sun
has it orbit let's try let's try to make
sure okay so the sun relies on something
outside of its own being to for its
existence right being it requires
something else to survive that well
that's that yeah that's outside of it
being that's outside of it being when
you say being what do you mean by that a
being is is it's it's ontology what it
is it's its existence. So so something
else that exists gives gives itself
existence. So another being which
is
brother that's please please let's so so
just to solidify so dependency is
something that relies on another being
for its existence or on another thing
for it existence. Can we can we can we
solidify on being? So would you say that
a thing is another I don't require a
water is not a being. I require water
water is a being water. So being is just
a is a state of existence. It has onto
if that's your definition of being then
yes. Okay. Cool. Yes. All right. Cool.
So so dependency you rely on another
being for your existence. All right
let's go on. That's my view. So you said
that Jesus is independent. Yeah. He's
independent. That is not independency
because Jesus is number one. Jesus could
be any other way. He could be any other
way. What did Jesus look like? I don't
know. Is there anything you have about
You're talking about his human nature?
Yes. Well, you're talking about his
divine nature. No, I'm talking about his
human nature. What did he look like? I I
don't know. Did he have two arms? Yes,
he did. Could he been born with no arm?
Uh, possibly. Okay. So, he can be any
other way. So, he's dependent. Oh, yeah.
But you're talking about his human
nature versus his divine natur. No, no,
no. I'm not talking
about I'm saying I'm saying Jesus. I
would agree that the human nature is
dependent. I would agree. Okay. But
okay. Okay. If it's dependent, then you
cannot have an independent regressive
dependent thing. It has to depend on
something that's independent. So what is
the independent thing? Uh Jesus's divine
nature. So because Jesus Let me finish.
Let me finish. Let me answer in full.
Okay. Because Jesus has a divine nature.
He has a a nature that is independent.
Okay. You can't be dependent independent
at the same time. Yeah. Well, I I agree
that you can't be dependent and
independent at the same time in the same
sense. I'm not saying that Jesus is
independent in regards to his divine
nature, dependent in regards to his
human nature. But my argument is the
following. I told you there are three
types of existence.
triangle square. If you if I'll give you
a little recap there. Let's say this
because the triangle and square
distinct, right? The triangle has three
sides. The square has four sides. So the
triangle, let's name the triangle Jesus.
And let's name the square the father.
No, no, no. Let's No, no, no. Was it?
No. Let's name the triangle flesh and
name the square divine. No, no. Because
you know why? Because there are two
separate composite beings. Let me tell
you, let me let me let me finish. Let me
finish. Let me finish. Cuz you know
where this going. No. Yes. I'll be
laughing if I was you too. I'll be
laughing if I was you too. You know when
the nerves come up, you got to you got
to release it one blah blah blah. It's
either by farting or laughing. Yes.
Okay. So now guys, the square the the
triangle and square are two opposites.
So I said an impossible existence is
what? To have a triangle where they're
impossible. It's just the same way of
saying dependent independent. Okay, two
opposites black white. So now and then I
said there are dependent things like
myself. I I depend on water, sleep,
shelter, food and many other things to
survive. We I asked a question is Jesus
dependent or independent? He said he's
independent. I said to him no because
Jesus when he was born could have been
born with one with one arm missing. He
said yes. That shows he's composed of
pieces. He could be any other way and he
is dependent. And I said it depends on
where he goes. He depends on his
independence. No. Can I can I respond to
this? All right. Thank you. So you're
you're conflating categories. So when
you ask me is Jesus dependent or
independent, I said independent. That's
in regards to his divine nature. He's uh
the dependency. The human nature is
dependent. Okay. It's composite. Of
course. Now, you said that this is like
doing a a
Yeah, that's me. You said you said that
this is like doing a squared circle.
Now, let me ask you this cuz I agree
with you that a square and square and
circle cannot be a triangle square.
Sorry. A triangle square cannot be the
same thing, right? Now, let me ask you
this. Can a triangle and a square be put
next to each other? Yeah. Okay. Is that
a contradiction? No. Okay. So I'm not
saying that the divine nature and the
human nature are intertwined and mixed
in are the same exact thing. I'm saying
that they're next to each other. They're
united in the person of Jesus next to
No. When you mix them next when you mix
them next to each other united you unite
them as one force of the triangle
square. You That's why I said it's an
impossible existence because you can't
have triangle square. They're distinct.
That's what I'm saying. That's not a
triangle next to each other. I have a
triangle and I have a square. No, it
looks like a house. It's like a square
and a triangle. It's like a little house
in it. Yeah. Yeah. But it doesn't work
here because the house just fell apart.
You know why? Because I'm saying, "Can
you have a triangle square?" He's
saying, "No." When you put the triangle
and square together, if you look at it,
it looks like a little house. Yeah. But
the how your argument of houses is fell
apart. I'm saying the following because
you're saying, "Can you have a square
and triangle put together?" I said,
"Yes." And it doesn't contradict. I
said, "Can you have a triangle square?"
Right? And I say, "No." Right? So, so
look, notice, let's get on the same
page. Okay? You and I both agree that
you cannot have a triangle and a square
in the same way, in the same sense.
Okay? We agree. What does that remind
you? Once you see that again hold a
second I'll say it again sure for the
audience. You cannot have a triangle and
a square in the same way in the same
sense. Wow. So understand Jesus and the
father Ali follow what I'm saying.
Follow what I'm saying. Okay. So what
I'm
saying what I'm saying is is that we
have a triangle and we have a square
next to each other united. Not that
they're mixed. Not that it's they're
combined. They're united in the person.
Okay. So I'm not saying that Jesus is
independent and dependent in the same
exact way in the same sense. That would
be a contradiction. I'm saying that he
has a nature that is independent and a
nature that is dependent. Two different
natures united in the person. That's
called the hypoatic union. This is
Christian theology. That's some that's
some that's some hypo
hypoatic. You don't know how to do it.
So wait wait wait. Okay. So so now so
now it's my turn. Okay. So So when you
so when you talk about composite, right?
When you talk about composite, I would
agree that the human nature is
composite, right? It has soul, mind, you
know, arms, legs and stuff like that.
The divine nature, it's not. It's not
made up in parts. You are different
though. You believe in Allah. You don't
believe that Allah is made up of a
parts, but you believe he has a hand.
You believe he has a shin, right? You
believe he has eyes. And now you say
that these things are not like how you
understand or how you know you don't ask
the how. I understand. But here's my
question. Is Allah identical to his
hands, for example? Okay. So, I
finished. Yes. Okay. So, I asked him the
question. You guys heard it for
yourself. In the beginning when he said
yes when he said that they are not they
cannot be the same. If only he just
changed the word triangle to Jesus and
the square to the father that look all
you have to do is guys when he says
triangle Jesus square father it's over.
The game is over. You know why? Because
I'm telling you he's joining them
together as one uh um like they're
distinct. He's saying that you can have
a square and you join them together
unification. I'm saying that can you
have a dependent independent being? Yes
or no? I just told you I already
answered that. Yes or no? Dependent
independent. Notice how you didn't
answer my question. I am. I am. Can you
have a dependent independent? What was
my question? I'm I'm saying to you very
clearly that a question. Listen listen.
You said that the square and the
triangle are unification. So you're
saying that the dependent and
independent came together. They're
united in the person. Exactly. And I'm
saying that goes against my
argument because dependency is something
that relies on something else for his
existence. Number one, it is composed of
pieces. Number three, it can't be any
other way. Now Jesus demonstrates that
how he's composed of pieces. You got to
deal with my question. He can be any
other way and he is dependent. All he's
done is the following. He goes, they're
unified. Meaning the following. Jesus is
dependent. Jesus is dependent. What did
I say and independent at the same time?
What? What did I say? That's a
contradiction, bro. Okay. So, triangle
square impossible existence. Looks like
we got existence. So, let me let me make
my argument. Let me finish. This is the
reason why why tohed and Islam make
sense. That's the reason why we have
hundreds of Christians coming to Islam
in this table. You know why? Because
every time we ask a Christian, why did
you leave Christianity? The first thing
they say is not morality. You know what
they say? Because no, no, not even. They
don't even say. They say we left because
there's no in Christianity. They say
because of the trinity. Because of the
trinity. because of the trinity. You
know why? Because the reason why no no
no no I'm making an argument. We say you
cannot have an infinite regress of
dependent things. Everything dependent
has to rely on something that is
independent and that has to be one true
God which is Allah. Now you might come
and say why Allah but not Jesus. That's
not what I asked. Can I ask my own
question? So I'm asking you a question.
No stop. You already made your argument.
Is he dependent or independent? I
already answered this. No, you didn't.
Okay. I'll answer it again but this time
you have to deal with my question. Okay.
Cuz you cuz you brought in some heat. I
just did. Okay. Okay. You feel like you
just did. We'll see. All right. So,
we'll do this again. I'll say it for one
last time so it's not circular for our
audience. They're going to get bored of,
you know, this whole thing. Okay. You
have the divine nature. You have the
human nature. You paying attention?
Yeah. Yeah. Have to pack the table. It's
closing. Yeah. That's fine. But we're
still here. Okay. I
need I got you. I got you. So, all
right. So, you got the divine nature,
got the human nature. They're not mixed.
They're not intertwined. They're united
in the person. So, I'm not saying that
the divine nature is is not divine in
the same way. I'm not saying that the
human nature is divine at the same time.
No, I'm saying he has a he's fully human
nature, a fully divine nature, united in
the person of Jesus. A triangle and a
square next to each other, not
intertwined, next to each other. As you
agree that that's not a contradiction.
Okay. Now, when I'm talking about the
dependency, the human nature is
dependent, right? It was made. It was
created at some point. But his divine
nature is eternal. It always existed.
Okay? And it's whole. It's not made up
of parts. But you don't believe that
Allah has a hypoatic union. You don't
believe that Allah incarnated in flesh.
You believe Allah has one nature. So you
said that makes more sense than Trinity
and the hypoatic union. So if you're
talking about composite, my question is
this. Allah has hands. Allah has a shin.
Is Allah's hands are Allah's hands
identical to his shin? Okay. So you've
asked me the question. Yeah, please. So
your question of Allah's shin and his
attributes last the first thing is about
the crime on the square. Look, I affirm
I affirm that's why I said to you
composed of pieces. I affirm Allah
subhana wa ta'ala's hands away before
his majesty. I affirm one of that. I
have no problem with all of that. My
argument is but my argument is not
identical because I'm saying I'm saying
no no no. No, no, no. I'm saying hands
identical. Listen to me. Listen to me.
Listen to me the following. I'm saying
to you that when we're talking about the
triangle square, you said they they come
together, the the father and the Jesus,
the fully man, fully God, they comes.
No, no, no. I am. When you say the fully
man and fully God in one nature, can you
explain to me how does a triangle and
square come together? What do you call a
triangle square coming together? I I
will I'll explain that. You need to
explain that next. No, no, no. I'll
explain
like you got to you promised you would
answer. I I am. I I just said to you,
it's a yes or no. It's not yes or no.
It's all first. First you need are
Allah's hands identical to his first you
need to do is listen this okay I'm
saying to you Allah is not composed of
pieces we don't we don't believe that so
is his hand are his hands identical to
the we don't believe that listen what
I'm saying so then answer this question
you are not answering the triangle
square argument I literally dealt with
that no you didn't you said when you
bring them together I'm saying when
you're not satisfied with my answer you
if you're not satisfied Thank you my
question when you have a you cannot have
a triangle and square come together what
shape would be you can't
Wait, I can I can literally draw on
paper. When did I say next to each
other? You literally said when did I say
next to each other? You literally told
me I said I'm saying my argument is not
next to each other. Can you have a
triangle square?
I said can you have a what do you call
it? What do you call it? What's the
shape called? Okay. Triangle and square
can come together. You can call it
whatever you want. So you said what is
the shape called? You said triangle
square. A triangle and a square next to
each other. They can be next to each
other. Yes, you did. It's on camera.
It's on your own stream. So you It's on
your own stream. Alhamdulillah. You know
it. I can see you sister. Focus with me.
Triangle square. Focus with me. Can you
have a triangle square? Stop. I didn't
say I didn't say together. You already I
said can you have a triangle? You can
have a triangle and a square next to
each other and it's not I know that. I
know. But I never said that. I'm saying
triangle square together.
Dude, you please. Okay. Look, stop.
Please. Me and you. You got to deal with
question. We're standing next to each
other. You You have to deal with the
question. The question, my friend, you
said that to Heidi is better than the
Trinity and I just demonstrated. So, are
Okay. Are Allah's hands identical with
his shin? Yes or no? No. What's your
point? Okay, good. So,
what's not composed of pieces? We affirm
that. We affirm his hands. We affirm the
shin. We But they're not identical.
Those are different. Those are different
parts of them, right? No, you said
parts. I didn't say parts. Okay. So, is
you said parts. You said they're not
identical. Okay. Let me Is Allah
identical to his name? We don't have
parts. That's what I'm saying. You just
described exactly. So, I'm asking a
simple question. This is why you're
running away from Can you have a
triangle square not next to each other?
I accept. I accept. See, there you go.
He knows. Are you okay? He knows. He
knows. This is why I said you're no
logic. I know what you're no logic. You
know why? Alhamdulillah. I'd rather be
I'd rather be slow than no logic. At
least it's some logic. Now guys, square
and triangle can come together. Together
meaning not
intertwined. I'm asking him the question
that and he knows very well. Do you
agree with that? A square and a triangle
agree with that can come together. Do
you agree with that? Yes. It would look
like a house. Okay. So a square and a
triangle could come together without it
being intertwined and being the same
thing in the same sense. Of course not.
You can draw it. Okay. Exactly. But
that's not what I'm saying. But that's
not what I'm saying. I'm saying it's
not. How could anyone is that saying can
you have a circle next to a square? No.
Of course you can. I'm saying nature and
a divine nature united in a person.
They're not the same thing. Listen
listen listen carefully. Can you deal
with my I am. Look look look. You're not
you're not looking. And then answer the
question. Triangle has how many sides?
We already did this. We're not doing
this again. Three sides. I'll do it for
three sides. Not doing this again. A
square has how many sides? Four sides.
Look. Look guys. One is three. One is
four. One looks like this. One looks
like
that. One, one looks like this. No, no
Illuminati, guys. No Illuminati here.
Okay.
Now, no Illuminati. Now, guys, can you
look? Think about this. Look, he knows
what's coming. No, guys. I'm saying to
him, one has three sides, one has four
sides. One looks totally different
pattern. Total different shape. That's
why you don't debate now. Now,
alhamdulillah, you brother, it's very
clear. It's very clear, bro. Bro, you're
the one who run away. Alhamdulillah.
Yeah, you bro over there. You run away.
Alhamdulillah, I came to you. Please,
all those due respect, please, please,
man, you quit, brother. Let's go. Now,
I'm asking a simple question. I asked
him from the beginning, what is an
impossible existence? I said, a triangle
square, not a triangle next to a square.
So, an impossible existence, which is
what? Independent, dependent. The flesh,
the body, the flesh is dependent, but
the godly nature is independent. My
friend, we call that an oxymoron. We
call that a contradiction. We call that
black and white because they are two
total opposites. And our argument is
what for Islam? If something is
dependent which Jesus is dependent, what
does he depend on? He depends on the
independent being that is not made of
pieces is not cannot be any other way
and is necessary. That was my argument.
And he knew the moment he said Jesus is
dependent, the question I asked was who
does he depend on? He depends on the
independent being which is Allah. This
is why makes perfect sense. Okay. Thank
you. Any last words? Yeah, last last
words here. Um um when you say that
Allah's shin is not identical to his
hands, for example, now you have just
acknowledged that Allah has division
within himself and has parts. His hands
is one part of him. His shin is another
part of him. And you I think he would
also say that his eyes are not identical
to his shin. Um that his his his face is
not identical to his back. So you
believe in a composed god. You your is
mixed up with a contingent being. Not
only that, but your Quran says that
Allah can't even have a son unless he
has a mate. So, he's dependent. He could
have a son if he wanted to. The Quran
says this, he could have a son if he
wanted to, but Allah can't have a son
unless he had a mate, somebody to have a
son with. So, your God is dependent and
made of parts. Your very own argument
destroys Allah. Allah.
Okay. Tahed is over. Is it time to go?
You finished? T is over. Close. No, no,
no. Here, wait here. Done. Wait, let me
let me land this here. Let me land this
here. So, you know, you never flew to
land. I've been flying this whole time.
Man, I've been flying this whole time.
I'm carrying you, man. I've been
carrying you this whole time. Carry to
set you down slowly, though. But so,
what you're missing, Alidawa, is I I I
mean, I don't know. I think you might
get it, but you're probably purposely
not doing it for the audience. Like,
you're literally not dealing with what
I'm saying because you said what I'm
saying is not what you're saying, which
is our point. What you're saying is not
what we believe. Okay? You got to deal
with our belief. Don't straw man it. So,
but you're unable to engage straw man.
There's no man. It is. Well, actually
mango. Okay. So, when you That's a law.
So, when you when you can't engage with
my actual position and you haven't been
able to engage with it at all tonight,
that shows that you have to misrepresent
my position to have an argument. That
means you don't have an argument. And
then you're I I guess like projecting
contingency onto me as but you're a
Muslim. You're you you're a Muslim. You
believe that Allah has hands and feet
and chin and eyes and a back and are all
different parts of uh from each other.
They're not the same thing. So your
Allah is contingent. He's dependent and
made up of parts, not like the triune
God. So understand the hypoatic union
and then you'll do better next time.
Finished. Yeah. I told you that's what
the argument told me. Alhamdulillah. One
God, man. One man, guys. One God, no
partners, not a man, not not
independent. Guys, all you have to do is
just watch the video and you know
triangle just call triangle Jesus and
square call it the father and the
argument makes perfect sense. Dependent
independent, I'm not going to lie, man.
Some people I thought it was going to be
better arguments. Bloody hell, man. I
knew you wasn't going to bring better
arguments. You didn't disappoint.
There's god logic who believes in one
god. There's dog logic who obeys one
master and there's no logic free
trinity. And they're slow. They're slow
derog one god. Even a dog. Even a dog
has one last
dah. If you give a dog food, he will
obey you about the charity rather than
his hadith. No logic. Freeith, right?
Guys, just watch the video.
Alhamdulillah. Let's go to our donation.
Let's get Yeah. Yeah%. Let's go,
brothers and sisters. Watch that video.
Alhamdulillah. Let's go. Let's go. Let's
get the donations.
[Music]
It's God. It's God.